Unless you didn’t quite get enough info
from the title- yes, it is entirely possible
for a chicken to lay an egg that contains
another fully developed egg, what we now officially
dub an Xzibit Egg.
A wonderfully bizarre Matryoshka doll made
of protein and disgusting (when you think
about it) deliciousness.
As you may or may not know, a chicken is capable
of laying hundreds of eggs in a given year
and the presence of a male isn’t needed
or required for this to happen.
It’s only necessary if you want to have
the eggs fertilised.
As such, hens can happily lay a near endless
stream of eggs throughout their lives with
no problem, assuming they don’t decide to
start brooding.
To make sure this doesn’t happen, one simply
has to remove the laid eggs regularly.
What you might not know, though, is that a
chicken can’t lay an egg without one key
thing- light.
It turns out, there is a photo-receptive gland
in a chicken’s eye that, when exposed to
sufficient light, ultimately triggers the
release of the hormone that in turn spurs
egg production.
Particularly in winter months in certain areas,
depending on the type of chicken, this may
mean that naturally the chicken will not get
sufficient light in the winter to produce
enough of the necessary hormone to spur egg
production, conserving the resources of the
chicken in times when food in nature is scarce.
Luckily for farmers and French Toast lovers
everywhere, artificial light works just as
well as natural in this case.
(And, note: French Toast Most Definitely was
Not Invented by the French)
Once the egg has been released into the chicken’s
system, it is joined by a small disk of nutritional
material better known as the yolk, all while
the chicken’s uterus fills with albumen
(egg white).
Once this cocktail is done floating around
in the chicken’s system, a thin, inner membrane
from the inside of the chicken’s uterus
forms around the egg.
After this, a more sturdy, outer membrane
mostly composed of calcium carbonate forms
around the whole thing, creating a chicken
egg as we know it.
This ultimately gets expelled from the same
orifice that the chicken poops out of.
Yes, this is what you’re scrambling up and
ingesting in the morning.
All that said, in juvenile chickens, this
incredibly complex and remarkably efficient
(considering a chicken can lay almost an egg
per day) process can get muddled, and while
a chicken is in the middle of forming one
egg, their bodies can sometimes send the signal
to create a second before the first is done
forming.
Eggs formed in this way are characterised
by having two (or more) yolks.
As such, they’re unimaginatively referred
to as “double/triple/etc. yolk eggs”.
We only say unimaginatively because eggs without
a yolk are given a much more inventive name
of “fart eggs”, or sometimes in polite
company “wind eggs”.
This brings us back to the title of this post.
Double shelled eggs are much more rare than
multi-yolked eggs and, as explained in this
New Scientist video, occur when abnormal contractions
result in the egg getting pushed back up into
the uterus.
The egg can then potentially stick around
for a second round of full egg development,
before ultimately being expelled.